we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p you know yesterday i
played a voicemail where someone
corrected my pronunciation of the city
in texas where the recent mass shooting
took place and i explained you know the
problem is
for me i see as a native spanish speaker
i see it and for me it's ubalde and so i
don't know if it's uvaldi or uvalde
these are all incorrect anglicized
pronunciations for me it's ubalde but i
don't tend to use those pronunciations
because people get all worked up about
it
the voicemail i received about it case
in point refers to my spanish
pronunciations as exaggerated that's my
whole point they're not exaggerated
they're just the pronunciations listen
to this
david i just wanted to say
i love it when you do your sort of
exaggerated spanish pronunciation
this is exactly he says he loves it but
he's still calling them exaggerated i i
don't find it offensive i just find it
funny that
just the real pronunciations
attract so much attention and are called
exaggerated they're just the
pronunciations it's sort of like if i
say apple
wow
what an exaggerated american
pronunciation of that no it's just how
you say apple in english it's like if
i'm speaking in spanish
and i refer to the former president of
the uh
united states
uh i say donald trump it's not an
exaggerated english pronunciation it's
just the pronunciation of names and
where it's it's i find it very uh
refreshing and uh i find it delightful
to listen to
good i don't know how to say you valde
in fact whenever i hear the word my
brain immediately goes to vivaldi the uh
yes of course the composer of the four
seasons and many other great pieces
italian baroque composer who wrote the
four seasons unless there's things maybe
on the bonus show and you have time
maybe you can like i know you talk about
baseball sometimes maybe you can uh read
the starting lineups of your favorite
team or something and pronounce all the
names for us that would be a lot of fun
thanks david
i love the show and yeah
we'll turn it into a uh
we'll turn it
into a sideshow jd martinez that'll be a
special uh that if we get to our 1.5
million subscribers i'll just read read
spanish names all right okay anyway it's
not a big deal but it is funny
on the bonus show today by the way we
will talk about following the uvalde
school shooting
canada is proposing new gun safety
regulations canada is doing more as a
result of the school shooting in the u.s
than the u.s is doing at least for now
we are going to talk about
one of the victims that was shot in the
brooklyn subway mass shooting another
recent mass shooting
she is suing the gun maker glock for
damages and we're going to talk about
um the impact of such a lawsuit
and we have not spoken about this on the
show or the bonus show at all
but it is finally over other than all of
the appeals that are coming the johnny
depp amber heard case is finally over it
has captivated much of the country
although i don't know that my audience
has been that interested in it for uh
weeks if not months
johnny depp mostly won his defamation
case against amber heard my interest in
it now
are the extrapolations that are being
made about the metoo movement about male
victims of domestic violence and so many
different things so we will finally
address it now that it's over mostly on
the bonus show
sign up for the bonus show at
joinpacman.com
you can use the coupon code big voting
22
but remember alex jones hates the bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad right
thank your lucky stars every day you're
not dave pacman well many people do okay
thank you alex you can sign up at
joinpakman.com coupon code big voting22
all of those stories and more today